OK, so many of you have asked me to talk about
this.
I've gotten dozens of emails, a handful of
voicemails, a bunch of messages during live
stream saying, David, you really need to investigate
and talk about some of the claims that are
being made by members of Congress and their
staff, that some aspect of the Trump riots
suggest some kind of inside job or coordination
either with members of Congress or with with
law enforcement.
And I think it's very important.
It would be irresponsible for me not to say
that at this point what we have is a set of
allegations, many of which are still being
investigated and sort of nebulous.
But this has come to a level where we should
talk about it.
So there's a few different things going on
here.
First of all, there have been concerning patterns
of posts and communications involving some
right wing members of Congress, in particular
new Congresswoman Lauren Bobert.
And it sort of exceeds the scope of this segment
to go through the minutia piece by piece.
But you can easily Google this and sort of
explore this path yourself, where she appears
to have been communicating and putting out
information that could just be sort of generally
supportive of the idea of of a of a big protest,
which is what Donald Trump is claiming he
did.
But it ended up inciting a riot or maybe based
on her being pictured with some individuals
that seemed to be riot folks.
Maybe she was in some way connected or involved.
And there are sort of a number of allegations
along that front.
There is also the very disturbing allegation
that has come from a Capitol Hill staffer.
That office panic buttons were removed in
advance of the pro Trump riotous insurrection.
Her name is Sarah Growe.
She's the chief of staff of Democratic Congresswoman
Ayanna Pressley.
And she said that she, along with others,
were taking refuge in Ianna Presley's office
as protesters and rioters flooded in and that
they barricaded the door with furniture and
they were in there.
And then they looked for the panic buttons
and the panic buttons were gone, saying every
panic button in my office had been torn out
and saying they could not find any rationale
as to why that took place, saying they've
used them before, that they had not switched
offices and that there were panic buttons
in that office which were subsequently gone.
What is the explanation for that?
We don't know.
We simply don't know.
At this point in time it's being investigated
and it should be investigated.
We also heard from Congressman James Clyburn
and James Clyburn, Clyburn explained.
I'm going to play a clip for you momentarily
that he has a marked office at the Capitol,
which says Congressman James Clyburn, that
that is marked office, but that as majority
whip, he tends to work at an unmarked office
in a different part of the building and that
somehow the riders knew exactly where to go,
even though it was an unmarked office.
This is him explaining it.
Take a listen to this.
The next part of this, which is what makes
this even more troubling with what you were
sharing with our folks this morning.
Part two of this, of what you were reporting
about is talk about the damage to your offices.
You have two different offices in the Capitol.
Explain it to our viewers.
Well, I have an office in the capital, which
is in the so-called Lincoln Room, named after
Abraham Lincoln.
That office, that's my name on the door, and
the House majority whip above the door.
It is just off of Statuary Hall.
Anybody walking through Statuary Hall can
see that office.
Now, that's not where I do.
Most of my work up on the third floor is where
I do most of my work.
And there are many members of the United States
Congress right now who could not tell you
for that office is and could not find that
office if they needed to.
Yeah, I've been there.
It's hard to find, sir.
I agree.
It is not easy.
Yes.
Yeah, but they found it.
Nobody touched the door where my name is,
but they were on the floor and my staff was
inside my inner office.
Furniture piled at the door with people trying
to get in the door did not let them in.
My question is, how did they know where that
office was?
That, to me, needs a thorough investigation,
and I do believe that there are some sensitivities
here.
There were people taking selfies.
With these insurrectionist, something's wrong
here, right?
So, again, very troubling allegations.
The explanation for which, you know, individually
any of these stories might have some explanation
that's relatively benign.
I've not heard it yet.
And so I want to be, again, as I've said before,
an unending, unsatisfying bowl.
Endless skepticism gets us into conspiracy
theory territory where both evidence for and
lack of evidence and evidence against all
this, all is evidence for the conspiracy.
I'm not going to fall into that at this point.
I've seen enough that says to me I am not
understanding why these different things took
place, if indeed they took place as they are
being alleged.
And it certainly needs to be investigated.
And we've since learned about a number of
different officers involved with the Capitol
Police, Capitol Police officers who have been
suspended and are being investigated for their
roles.
And we already know it's not within the realm,
beyond the realm of reality, that Capitol
Police acted at least some people incorrectly
during this.
And it must be investigated how far this goes.
I think that that's roughly and I know that
many of you wish I could be more definitive
about this.
That's basically my thought about it at this
point in time.
The allegations are troubling.
And if they are true or even part of them
are true, there's quite a bit of explaining
that needs to be done.
We will continue following
it
up